Welcome back to recitation.
In this video, I'd like us
to do the following problem.
I want us to show that the
function, if I integrate
x to the n, e to the minus
x from 1 to infinity,
that that actually converges
for any value of n.
And I want us to show this
without using integration
by parts n times.
So I'd like you to
figure out a way
to show that this
integral converges.
And again, what we mean by
converges, is for a fixed value
here, say, some b,
if I let-- the limit
as b goes to infinity, that
that sequence of values
converges to a finite number.
That's what we mean, again, when
we say an integral converges.
Ultimately, we want to
show this is finite.
So show this is finite,
without using integration
by parts n times.
So I'll give you a little
while to work on it,
and then I'll be back, and I
will show you how I did it.
OK.
Welcome back.
Well, I want to
show you how we can
show that this integral
actually convergences for any n.
And I don't want to have
to use integration by parts
and kill off powers of
x in order to do that.
So again, the integral is from
1 to infinity of x to the n, e
to the minus x dx.
And if you recall,
Professor Jerison
was showing, in
the lecture video,
that if you can show even
from, not 1 to infinity,
but from very far
out to infinity,
that that integral
converges, from 1
to whatever the far-out value
is, this integral is finite.
OK?
Doesn't blow up.
It's going to be potentially
a very big number,
but it is going to
be a finite number.
There are no places
where we run into trouble
with this function.
It's a continuous function
from 1 to infinity.
So we can go very
far out and say, OK,
from very far out to infinity,
the integral converges.
And then that's
going to be enough.
So we did see that kind
of technique earlier.
But I just want to remind you,
that's what we're going to do.
Now, you might have
thought about this problem
and said, well, I
know that x to the n
is much smaller than e to the
x for values of x very large.
So you might have said-- I think
you used this notation also
in the lecture. x to
the n is much smaller
than e to the x for large x.
So what if we tried to do
a comparison with those two
functions?
We're going to see,
that's not quite enough.
But let's say x is very large,
and let's look at a comparison.
If I say, the
integral from, say,
some very large R to infinity of
x to the n e to the minus x dx,
it's certainly going to be
much smaller than the integral
from big R to infinity of e
to the x times e to the minus
x dx.
And you think, well,
you know, that's
a pretty good first step.
I'm doing all right.
But what happens here?
What's e to the x
times e to the minus x?
It's e to the x plus negative x,
so it's e to the 0, so it's 1.
So this is integrating
the constant 1.
Well, the constant 1 from R
to infinity, think of that.
It's the line y equals
1 from R to infinity.
It's an arbitrarily
long rectangle.
That's got a lot of area.
It's got infinite area.
So this integral diverges.
That doesn't mean this
one diverges, right?
Because this one is
smaller than that one.
So this one here
could still converge,
even though this
integral diverged.
Again, let me remind you.
Why does this integral diverge?
Because this is
actually equal to 1.
If I integrate 1
from R to infinity,
I get something infinite.
So you might have
started with that,
but that's not
quite good enough.
Right?
What is going to
be good enough, is
if I pick any constant
in front of this n--
I can put any constant in
front of this n I want,
bigger than 1.
And that's going to help us out.
So I'm going to
pick the constant 2,
because it's going to be easy,
and it's a nice fixed number.
If I-- so this is how you do
it correctly, or one strategy
to do it correctly.
If I take x to the 2n, instead
of just x to the n, for any n,
there's some R big enough
so that x to the 2n
is much less than e
to the x for all x
bigger than or equal to some R.
So if I go far enough out
in x-values, x to the 2n
is much smaller than e to the x.
So let's say that that
value is capital R,
and then we're much smaller.
This is not very formal,
but it's getting closer
to a formal kind of thing.
Then that means x to
the n is much smaller
than e to the x over 2.
Right?
And that's going to be the key.
Let's anticipate why that is.
The problem with the
substitution of e to the x
was that e to the x times e
to the minus x gave you 1.
But if I use e to
the x over 2, I'm
going to end up
with some function,
e to the minus
something, and that's
going to be good, because
that's going to converge.
So if you tried
e to the x first,
and you saw you didn't
get a good function,
you didn't have to stop there.
You could say,
well, I was close.
The problem is, I cancelled off
all the e to the minus power,
which is what I
want to keep around.
If I want to keep
some of that around,
then I have to have a little
less power of e to the x there.
I have to have-- I can't
just have e to the x.
I should have something like
square root of e to the x.
So e to the x over 2.
That's going to help us out.
So this is, this is
kind of, as you're
working on this type
of problem, this
is some of the thought process
you want to go through.
So what do we see here?
We have x to the n is much
less than e to the x over 2
for x bigger than or equal to r.
So now let's do
a comparison with
our new comparative function.
So I'm going to come over,
and this will be our last line
to finish this off.
So now we're integrating from
R to infinity x to the n,
e to the minus x dx.
And we know that's going to
be much less than integral
from R to infinity, e to the
x over 2, e to the minus x dx.
And now let's figure
out what this is.
e to the minus x plus x over
2 is e to the minus x over 2.
And the good news is, this
is, we know this converges.
I'll check, and I'll show you,
remind you that it converges.
But we know this converges.
And the reason is, because e to
the minus x is a function that
decays so fast as it goes to 0.
That's really why you
get the convergence.
Actually, you could even
compare this to x to the minus 2
right away.
And you could get
something like, you
know this decays faster
than x to the minus 2,
and we know x to the
minus 2 converges.
So you could even
compare it to that.
You could do a second
comparison in here.
But I'll actually
calculate this,
just to remind us
how we do this.
So e to the minus x over 2.
If I want to find
an antiderivative,
I'm going to guess and check.
I know I'm going to have an e
to the minus x over 2 again,
and then I need to be able
to kill off a negative 1/2.
So I should put a
negative 2 in front.
Let's double check.
This is basically a
substitution problem.
An easy substitution.
So e to the minus x over 2.
Its derivative is negative
1/2 x, and then itself again.
The negative 1/2 times
negative 2 gives me a 1.
So again, I'm just, it's an
easy substitution problem,
but I always want to check.
So I evaluate that
from R to infinity.
Well, the point is, e to the
minus infinity-- this is 0.
As x goes to infinity,
this quantity goes to 0.
So I get 0 minus a
negative 2, so plus 2, e
to the minus R over 2.
For some fixed, big R.
Well, that's finite.
That's a finite number.
So we come back here.
This integral converges.
That integral was this integral.
And this integral, then,
is bigger than this one.
So this one converges.
Now, this had a lot
of pieces to it,
so I'm going to remind us
sort of what was happening.
So let's go back to
the original function,
and I'll just take us back
through one more time.
OK.
So the original
problem was, show
that this integral from 1
to infinity of x to the n e
to the minus x dx converges.
And I reminded you that
you knew from lecture
that if I could show
that it converged
for some very large number
down here to infinity,
that was sufficient,
because this function is
continuous from 1 to infinity.
I don't have to
worry about places
where I might get infinite
area in a finite interval.
I'm always going to have finite
So if I start at some big R to
infinity and that converges,
then I'm good.
Because from 1 to R,
that'll be finite.
So then the point is,
you want to compare.
And I mentioned a comparison
that doesn't quite work,
but is a good first test.
Because you know
x to the n is much
less than e to the x for
a sufficiently large x.
You might think to
compare it to that,
but the problem again was when
we do that substitution, we
actually get an
integral that diverges.
But a divergent integral
bigger than something
doesn't mean this one diverges.
If the divergence
was-- the inequality
was the other way, then you
could show this one diverged.
But we actually show
convergence this way.
Or we're trying to show
convergence in this direction,
so we need to say, if
this one converges, then
that one converges.
This diverging doesn't tell
us anything about this.
So then we say, OK.
This one didn't work,
but it almost worked.
So what if I figure out a
way to compare x to the n
to a slightly smaller
thing than e to the x?
And that slightly smaller
thing is e to the x over 2.
It's not really
slightly smaller.
But the smaller function
is e to the x over 2.
OK?
And this is a way to think
about how that works.
Is that for any
power of x to the 2n,
I can still get
it smaller than e
to the x for some
sufficiently large number.
OK?
And you don't even have
to think about these R's
as being the same.
I can change them, I
can make this bigger.
This doesn't compare
to this problem, also.
So don't be confused
by those two R's.
OK.
So then we found something we
wanted to compare x to the n
with.
Then we come back over
here, and we actually
see that we get a good
comparison, because we're
able to see that the integral on
the right-hand side converges.
This integral is bigger
than this integral.
So this integral
converges, so we
know this integral converges.
And then, the integral
from 1 to R of this
is finite, so the
integral from 1
to infinity of this converges.
And that's sort of
the strategy for doing
these types of problems.
OK.
That's where I'll stop.